und wären Job beiden eben seinen Bürgern
die Tacos bezahlt müssen wir hier gerade
unserem Kanzler neues Kanzleramt
finanzieren
der regiert hier auf
25.000 Quadratmetern aber diese nicht
genug das Kanzleramt einfach zu klein
ganz klar und deshalb soll es jetzt für
777 Millionen Euro umgebaut werden 777
Millionen also eine gigantische Zahl und
das wäre in Deutschland in der Krise
steckt und ja jeden Cent umdrehen muss
unfassbar
darf ein bisschen mehr sein wie wäre es
mit einem Hubschrauber Landeplatz auf
Stelzen einer Kita und rund 4009 Büros
diese und viele weitere Extras soll die
geplante Erweiterung des Kanzleramts
haben es ist ein gigantisches Bauprojekt
inklusive gigantischer Kosten für
777 Millionen Euro soll die bisherige
Bürofläche von 25.000 Quadratmeter auf
50.000 Quadratmeter vergrößert werden
davon allein 2,8 Millionen Euro für die
Kita mit gerade einmal 15 Plätzen und 10
Millionen Euro für den Hedi Landeplatz
auf 23 Meter hohen Stelzen außerdem
geplant eine zweite kanzler-wohnung von
250 Quadratmetern Fertigstellung 2028
wow aber Moment mal damit wäre das
Kanzleramt größer als das Weiße Haus die
Downing Street number ten in London und
der elise-palast in Paris brauchen Olaf
Scholz und Co wirklich so viel Platz und
Politik zu machen offenbar schon Kritik
vom Bundesrechnungshof aus dem Herbst
2020 Abenteuer Bau verhalte ungehört
jetzt soll mitten in der schwersten
Krise der Bundesrepublik mit dem Bau
begonnen werden das Projekt ist völlig
überdimensioniert es passt nicht in die
Zeit und es haben ja schon einige davor
gewarnt unter anderem auch der
Bundesrechnungshof dass die
veranschlagten Kosten so nicht haltbar
sind wir kommen von 475 Millionen Euro
sind jetzt schon bei über 650 Millionen
Euro und ich gehe davon aus dass dieser
Bau nicht unter einer Milliarde Euro
mindestens zu haben wird wenn das
überhaupt eine Benchmark ist die
erreicht werden kann steigende Preise
wohin man nur schaut Corona pleitewellen
und ein drohender Blackout im Winter wie
passt da dieser protzbau ins Programm
tatsächlich stammt die ursprüngliche
Idee noch aus den Zeiten von
ex-kanzlerin Merkel damals ging es
Deutschland allerdings noch extrem gut
jetzt sieht das ganz anders aus doch
könnte man den Umbau noch stoppen würden
dafür Kosten anfallen eine bildanfrage
dazu liest das Kanzleramt unbeantwortet
aus meiner Sicht brauchen wir zurzeit
überhaupt keinen Neubau weil zu es geht
ja alle Mitarbeiter sind ausgelagert wir
haben Büroplätze in anderen Ministerien
die frei sind darüber hinaus haben wir
gelernt dass auch vieles von zu Hause
ausgeht Stichwort Homeoffice trotz
Krisenzeit soll der Bau durchgezogen
werden und dafür müssten laut the
pioneer 180 Bäume die bis zu 60 Jahre
alt sind gefällt und 40 weitere
umgesetzt werden 200 Bäume sollen dann
als Ausgleich im späteren kanzlergarten
gepflanzt werden
ist für uns am Kanzleramt also Viktor
777 Millionen Euro das muss man sich mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen was man
davon alles kaufen könnte woher nimmt
denn Scholz jetzt eigentlich die Kohle
ja Theresa Felix das ist Steuergeld 777
Millionen Euro Steuergeld mitten in der
Krise in der schlimmsten Krise der
Bundesrepublik in der Inflation Corona
Energiekrise Krieg das Land Geißeln
werden einfach mal 777 Millionen Euro
Steuergeld genommen ja Viktor du stehst
jetzt gerade da wo demnächst nichts mehr
stehen soll bzw wo die Bäume abgefällt
werden sollen zeig uns einmal ein
bisschen die Umgebung was da irgendwann
mal hinkommt und die andere Frage ist
das für die Grünen so überhaupt kein
Problem
das ist genau die richtige Frage theresa
ist es für die Grünen kein Problem hier
sollen so viele Bäume gefällt werden wir
haben es ja gerade gehört Lupinen Eichen
Robinien und das sind alles seltene
Bäume zum Teil sind sie 60 Jahre alt die
kommen einfach alle weg und ihr seht ja
hier ist eine schöne Flora um mich rum
das ist wirklich fast ein märchenhafter
Wald und das kommt alles weg wenn ihr
mal mir folgen wollt wir sehen hier also
ein schönes natürliches Paradies direkt
am Kanzleramt und kommt mal mit was man
hier alles sehen kann also wunderbare
baumwelten das kommt alles weg
schön unfassbar schade sehr schade muss
man sagen und wenn man den Bund der
Steuerzahler glaubt dann wird das alles
noch viel viel teurer als es vorher
veranschlagt ist schöner Plan vom
Kanzleramt mal sehen was die Bürger da
zu sagen danke schön
[Musik]